[Music]
and behind the mask Muse gotta wait for
a girl come on now submitted by kiss and
pays a popular anime girl on YouTube was
exposed the data as a middle-aged man
after his dream encountered a glitch oh
[ __ ] this was very common where a lot of
cross-dressing was happening in the
cosplay world is it a game doesn't mean
that like a cartoon glitched and it
showed his real face yeah damn see this
[ __ ] please show me so here's the clip
of when it happened there was a glitch
so this is what it what it looks like
usually I wasn't listening yeah crazy
voice that he can do though wait but I
don't understand so why is the camera on
him then because he's using a real-time
like oh like a face scanner oh so he's
like being the girl like oh so when he
moves the girl moves yeah was everyone
pissed that's cool
so this thing went viral because someone
captured it and then tweeted it out and
people were just laughing at it they're
like wow this is a guy behind it like
but the actual die-hard fans of this
character they're like it doesn't matter
it doesn't choose character themselves
I thought the people that are laughing
they're just trying to cover up that
they bust the nuts to this girl right
yeah is it sexual or what
jackoff this man I know it just this is
character it's called Nora Katz and she
plays video games and like she comments
like she streams just oh like a
character that's dreams yeah oh it's
kind of cool so cool yeah so uses like
advanced real-time motion capturing
technology where it converts all of his
body and facial movements into this
carriage that's so cool
episode when that guy is that character
guy and he does the politics and sure
the new oh no that's
yeah the cat thing or the doctor oh yeah
yeah the chameleon there yeah yeah
that's the same thing yeah kind of it's
got a watch back mirror i watch one of
them yeah wooden did you watch the girl
that was trying to go our friends we're
gonna get her points up that's a good
one that's a good one I want applies to
our life it is very pink that hole yeah
like that episode I'm glad this guy had
his clothes on it's so cool you could be
whatever character you want to be like
you know like it doesn't I find it very
odd that this guy chose I mean you know
to each their own
whatever your cup of tea is drink it but
why why do you choose to be a female cat
girl woody that's how he feels inside
maybe that and express it he wants to be
cute yeah maybe you realize he has like
a unique voice and you wanted to tell ya
it's like sometimes you know when you're
an artist and then like they make art
and that just is something they created
out of them but it's not like it's not
them right youth like they make this
beautiful art but like then you see the
artist you're like that guy made that
and that's kind of how that is we're
like the artist coming out of him but
it's inside he's a beautiful cute little
girl yeah it's like mr. nice piece
remembered mr. nice piece the old
grandpa that looks like a kung fu
warrior nice please that's cool
you know what's interesting is if you
think about the olden days in theater
all the women were men are all the
amendment women rules also is it Bart
Simpson voiced by yeah
kind of the opposite of that yeah how
popular is he as a youtuber for doing
that kind of [ __ ] what's up dad
that's pretty dope dude you know what
would upset me though is if I was
jacking off to a cam girl and then the
cam girl turns into like a big hairy man
oh that would that would scare me like
if technology got that good I
get that it's because your your
expectation was
you're gonna get a girl that you're
gonna want to [ __ ] here's a good
question have you guys ever had a sexual
dream where your partner turned into
somebody else that was very unappetizing
yep yeah I was having sex with a lady as
she turned to my mom my mom was [ __ ]
bouncing up on your shirt get the [ __ ]
off that was weird
oh yeah that's a should not sex with the
other [ __ ] women in your head I'm
like this in real life but then in the
[ __ ] dream that point point lucky at
least you get sex do not wake up
screaming dude I would have screamed so
[ __ ] loud you would I want to walk up
and bombing it on my chest it's a cold
ass water no unfortunately not
fortunately unfortunately I couldn't
bust nut there's been so many oh you
freaky tears ever since I was like a
teenager it's been like when I'm making
out with someone and then I move away
and it's my dad on my leash you're not
[ __ ] know there is some of them have
been oh and I wake up in like the whole
day I'm just like traumatized I would
wake up and I would start punching my
own face and you [ __ ] pervert yeah
having these dreams I'm like what is
wrong with me like do I have some sort
of like subconscious attraction to my
dad or something that what the [ __ ] but
then I realize later on as I grow older
and they're having issues maybe it is
that you can't explain your [ __ ]
dreams I always had them about old men
teachers like I don't like men I would
never be attracted to like just like old
like men like we would be doing an
exercise in class like in my dream and
then it would just turn into sex and and
then I'd wake up and be so confused and
you go to class and you can't like you
just see
naked it's just like so weird there look
like a foul walrus yes good like what
does that mean why'd that happen ever
had that happen and I'm glad it never
did because I had a dream where you turn
into a woman that's my favorite there's
a lot of like murder dreams like I'm
[ __ ] killing the [ __ ] out of people
that's a B no idea why that keeps
happening though he's been happening
like consecutive for the past four days
I mean you a lot of violent thoughts
though
it's never happened before till you know
it's I tell you is that melatonin [ __ ]
I'm taking it's like [ __ ] me up
you're probably very stressed out maybe
that's what it is Santa calm down man
coping is I'm not killing people really
killing animals no like demons oh [ __ ]
my oven that's okay like I had this
dream where I was in the car it was
raining outside and I supposed to get
inside this building a cinematic day the
only way that I could get in I bet your
jeans are so cinematic the only way I
can get in is if I go up on the roof so
I [ __ ] do that hook ship climbed up
right oh you're definitely doing yeah
I'm really fitting this right and I will
go down the [ __ ] you know the glass
top of the building I'm in my dream
[ __ ] I go in bow-bow I start knocking
people out right just shooting everybody
up it was [ __ ] amazing
that's time do you ever have a dream
where like you're doing all that kind of
stuff and then mid dream you realize
like wait I don't know how to do any of
this stuff and then you like lose your
ability to do it no in every dream I
know everything I'm not I do everything
in my dream to have a dream that like
I'm a fencer and like I'm about to like
do a sword fight and then I'm about to
do it and I'm like wait hold on a sword
fight and then I'm like [ __ ] he's gonna
kill me I turned back into myself too
much self-awareness and my dreams I have
a lot of dreams in my old homes me too
childhood homes or whatever and then
sometimes I go back to a scenario that
really happened oh [ __ ] I can redo
things that's really cool mine's the
opposite I have dreams in places I've
never been to and in three years later
I'm like what the [ __ ] boo boo this was
yeah this is literally my dream like I
saw this place already oh you can
remember cuz for me I get the data of a
feeling but then later on I remembered
oh yeah I don't
I have dreams that I married my
ex-boyfriend and I come home and my
nightmare yeah and I'm like wait [ __ ] I
don't love you why how did I end up back
in this and I'm like oh my god I married
this guy why'd I do this and I in my
head I remember like marrying someone I
was really attracted to and I can't
remember Steve until like the end of the
dream and then I'm like wait what about
Steve and then I leave it in the dreams
like wait you're my wife what are you
doing and I'm like no I'm not I wonder
what that dream means because I had a
similar dream to where I dreamt that I
ended up marrying my ex but then I'll
but I remembered Casey the whole time
I'm like no this can't happen no I said
no to you why are we together no what
happened like you're here you're real
because that's alternate reality where
you did stay with them and then when
you're dreaming you're channeling back
into that [ __ ] reality and they were
dreaming right now oh my god I would
love my alternate reality self
I'd kick so much ass I'm not scared of
heights of people's faces I can fly in
my dream that's the only thing I like
about my dreams I haven't flown in a
while yeah yeah as long as they fly in a
dive under water lucky lucky lucky easy
it is to [ __ ] run full face into a
[ __ ] glass mirror and they come out
the end and they just are blasting
people action movie dreams are you
swinging in are you swinging within a
cable and [ __ ] do like ran full force
bow right through and I came that sort
of blasting you're so sad when you wake
up you're like wait is my Honda Element
real thank God I don't have the
Batmobile I guess see why you don't want
to train anymore did you do all that
[ __ ] in your hand you're exhausted when
you wake exhausted in my dreams working
out too hard you should get a heart
monitor so that you see if you worked
out at all or hit that like cardio zone
in the dream yeah it's pretty awesome
though